- Your new book.
So, it's called "Making a Scene".
So, why did you name it that?
- Well, it sort of has two meanings.
One is about how art is really healing.
And for me that has been acting
and in acting you make scenes,
whether it's in a play or like a movie.
And the other sort of the symbolic idea
of what it means when
somebody makes a scene.
And growing up in the South,
it wasn't considered ladylike.
- Girl, I know.
I grew up there.
- Yeah.
- But you know, the thing is
if you're an emotional person,
like I was.
(Kelly blows raspberry)
Yeah, repressed feelings don't go away
just because you will them too.
They're inevitably gonna come out.
- Yeah.
- In another way.
And I think there was like
this big fiasco on Twitter
'cause I said some very
negative things about a show
that I truly loved being on,
but it was within the context
of being sexually harassed on that show.
- Oh.
- Being intimidated,
being controlled,
and me wanting to swallow
that and hide that
so I didn't stain the reputation
of the only Asian-American
networks that come.
- Do you feel obligated to say something?
Do you react ever?
Like, you know what I'm saying?
- Well, I mean, there was
definitely a social media pile on
which I understood because
if you don't know me,
it just looks like, "Oh,
she had this huge hit movie
and now she thinks she's
outgrown the show,"
which wasn't-
- Yeah, but you led
with you don't know me.
Which is they don't know you though.
- Yeah, but it's easy to
think you know a public figure
based on-
- Yeah.
- The limited information
that you have of them.
It's easy to construct that narrative.
But I had been a public
figure for a while then,
so I thought I was pretty
strong and pretty capable.
But it was actually a few DMs
from a former colleague
of mine, an Asian actress
who you think she'd be on your side.
That sort of convinced me that
life, my life was worthless.
And I ended up in the hospital
because I tried to take my own
life, which was really scary.
- Yeah.
- But ultimately, it was a good thing
because it made me seek help.
- Yeah.
- And I wouldn't
have been able to talk
about it three years ago,
because I was still very
like raw and wounded.
- Yeah.
- But I think
the thing I've learned now is
that through a lot of therapy
and looking at what my values truly are,
I've developed the tools to handle it.
- Yeah.
- And so,
I wanna talk about it so other young women
who might be struggling
with the same thing
know they're not alone
and that there is a light
at the end of the tunnel.
It takes work.
- Yeah.
Work.
- But you can get there.